- So, we're celebrating
all the feels February
'cause it's Valentine's Day,
so you have anybody special?
- I do, my boyfriend
Anthony, the love of my life.
Yes.
I don't know what we're going to do,
we're probably just gonna
stay at home and just eat.
like we always do, but--
- [Kelly] That's the best date ever!
Oh, y'all are adorable!
- [Lana] That's us.
- [Kelly] Look at him in that hat, okay!
Look at this one!
- [Lana] That's my puppy, Emmy.
- Emmy's adorable.
I love your man, but I
love him more, yeah yeah.
Or her?
Emmy's a girl, right?
Yes yes yes, how old?
- We just celebrated her
one year, one years old,
and one year being with us,
'cause we got her at five weeks.
And she knows, she knows
that it's her one year
because we woke up, and I'm a little sick,
so Anthony went and took
her out on her morning walk.
And she pooped in the shape of a heart.
(audience laughs)
Now, I would like to say
that I have a picture of the said poop.
- That's impressive.
- Yeah.
- And I can show it to you.
- I feel challenged.
(audience laughs)
- I just wanna, I wanted to know
if you feel like "Mm, not
the vibe," please look away,
but we have a photo.
You have a photo of the heart poop?
- Of the heart poop.
- Okay, if you wanna look
at the heart poop, go ahead.
- She knows, dogs know!
- If you don't, no, you know.
I wanna look at the heart poop!
(audience screams)
(man groans)
- Yeah.
That's a talent.
- That's actually
very impressive!
- Happy Valentine's Day, you guys!
(audience chuckles)
- I mean, the only thing better
is if she just sat behind it and was like.
Like, after.